nicolas dupont aignan se présente comme
le candidat des petits mais pas comme un
petit candidat il est avec nous ce soir
bonsoir soir merci d'être avec nous le
patriotisme les références ce gaulliste
le rejet de l'europe actuelle et de
l'euro et bien tout cela vous anime
depuis quelques semaines que l'égalité
parfaite des temps de parole vous permet
enfin d'être exposée dans les médias
vous aurez des choses à dire sur ce
sujet je crois d'ailleurs vous contester
certaines règles non pas du csa mais
mais des médias eux mêmes c'est bien ça
nicolas dupont-aignan sur le plan
économique les experts ont des doutes
j'ai envie de dire aux parfois même des
certitudes ils disent à propos du
programme de marine le pen la sortie de
l'euro qu'il nous mènerait sans doute à
la ruine sur ce plan là vous répondrai
dans un instant aux questions d'hervé
ascain de l' agence france-presse
et puis perrine tarneaud 2 public sénat
nous rejoindra pour la troisième partie
de cette émission d'abord nicolas dupont
aignan l' après toulouse et montauban
al jazeera donc ne diffusera pas la
vidéo du tueur qui l'a reçue par par
voie postale c'est évidemment un
soulagement
un soulagement bas c'est évident c'était
tellement monstrueux ça aurait été un
second crime
après le premier est honteux comme le
dit nicolas sarkozy de dénoncer le
travail
peut-être simplement de s'interroger sur
le travail des forces de l'ordre non
mais là est surveillant le président de
la république comme c'est dommage parce
que le président de la république a été
digne pendant cette période est à
nouveau retomber dans les excès moi j'ai
félicité les forces de l'ordre leur
sang-froid leur capacité à arrêter le
meurtrier pour autant on a quand même le
droit de s'interroger dans une
démocratie sur le fonctionnement d'un
système de renseignement et quand madame
joly par exemple 10 cas pas un pays
démocratique où les deux responsables de
la police
il ré pavaner devant les médias comme en
france elle a raison je veux dire une
chose est de conforter les forces de
l'ordre dans l'opération et elles ont
été remarquables une autre chose est de
s'interroger quand même sur l'incapacité
de
surveillance d'un homme qui avait
accumulé un stock d'armes incroyable qui
était interdit de vol pour aller aux
états unis et qui avait été en
afghanistan
par ailleurs les ferries d'ailleurs moi
je crois qu'il ne faut pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu je crois qu'il faut
un juste équilibre
le problème de fond c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les forces de police de gendarmerie les
forces judiciaires les douanes n'ont pas
les moyens nécessaires à l'exercice de
leurs missions
donc on demande à des gens qui sont je
l' ai dit plusieurs fois des héros de
faire un travail dont ils n'ont pas les
moyens qu'elles sont deux moyens pour
cette une passion c'est évident il
souriait voir les policiers les
gendarmes
ce sont des gens admirables et
simplement sont démunis c'est la grande
misère de l'état dernier vous que ce
manque de moyens a conduit à des failles
je n'en sais rien mais je demande qu'on
ait le droit de s'interroger quelles
sont les questions que vous vous posez
les clans sur le swing sur le sol
allemand on a subi
est ce qu'on a les moyens de suivre
est-ce que ce service à tous les moyens
nécessaires
est ce qu'il n'est pas distrait par
d'autres occupations
est ce que les caméras j'en sais rien il
faut demander est ce que en tout cas moi
je sais qu'il faut rétablir le contrôle
aux frontières pour lutter contre le
trafic d'armes
on demande à la police et la gendarmerie
avec douze mille agents de moi 2000 en
cinq ans de faire un travail alors même
qu'on a ouvert toutes les frontières
mais on voit le résultat insécurité
galopante de trafic d'armes eu homicide
en permanence dans beaucoup de villes de
france
ça peut plus durer alors que le
président de la république ne mélange
pas tout la nation a été unanime
derrière ces policiers et gendarmes
maintenant on a quand même le droit de
s'interroger sur des dysfonctionnements
bernard squarcini le patron de la des
séries a démenti aujourd'hui que mohamed
merah fut un indicateur est ce que vous
avez pu avoir ce genre d'interrogations
vos jeux ni même vais même pas pensé
mais vous voyez je suis naïf
mais je trouve d'ailleurs surprenant que
les ministres le ministère ne s'exprime
pas j'estime que les fonctionnaires sont
là pour obéir au gouvernement et non pas
pour parler à la place des ministres et
j'ai été très étonné de voir donc clos
bien c'était peut-être beaucoup exprimé
sur le site non pas du tout lors de la
non pas du tout logiciel est reproché
jeunes à reprocher leur boulot jamais en
revanche j'estime que ce n'est pas des
policiers d'aline sur les plateaux de
télévision le chef de l'état en tout cas
vu accélérer les procédures d'expulsion
des extrémistes et il veut interdire
d'entrer également ceux qui contestent
des valeurs de la république tout ça
bien sûr va dans le bon sens et à en
pleurer
retrouvez le consensus dans mon peut
enfoncer les portes du verte comme ça
toute la journée
et pourquoi il n'a pas fait avant ça
fait cinq ans que ça se fait pas ça fait
cinq ans qu'ils aient des prêches de
haine dans certaines mosquées
c'est curieux donc soit cela n'a pas été
fait pendant cinq ans et c'est quand
même grave et il devrait plutôt rendre
des comptes
soit il dit ce qui se fait et c'est son
boulot c'est normal donc vous savez je
crois que les français vont être lassé
de ces gesticulations présidentielles
très là c'est parce que on attend du
président de la république
du sérieux il a été remarquable pendant
la période du drame est là à nouveau
l'esprit politiciens reprend le dessus
ça ne trompera personne moi je crois que
les français attendent de la cohérence
donc que le président de la république
nous explique comment il va faire pour
mettre davantage de policiers de
gendarmes plutôt que de donner de
l'argent à des braves en grèce ça sera
beaucoup plus utile et moi je propose et
je suis candidat pour ça écouter jusqu'à
maintenant c était d de l'argent pour
les banques en grèce et pas pour les
policiers donc moi je suis candidat
parce que je veux qu'on sorte de cette
politique alors avant du spectacle vous
aborder aussi tout de suite la question
européenne on va y revenir un peu plus
tôt ce que l'armée nous attaque le
showbiz mais on a l'habitude ça fait
cinq ans que ça dure le show biz le
showbiz sur une huilerie aussi atroce
non le showbiz après après je parle pas
je plus précis j'ai parole précise après
le président était remarquable 2021
pendant la belle et là on recommence des
annonces eux c'est honteux de se poser
des questions va on est en démocratie
là on est depuis cinq ans dans un
système de showbiz politique
oui des annonces jamais suivies d'effets
ce appelle ça le showbiz des annonces
jamais suivies d'effet je dis qu'on a
voté ici dans cette maison au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale et j'ai voté des
lois
fruit de dix loi
ces lois ne sont pas appliquées alors
avant d'en inventer de nouvelles
j'aimerais qu'on puisse appliquer les
lois qui existent selouane la république
un mot sur les valeurs de la république
et les valeurs tout court que vous
défendez nicolas dupont aignan comment
est-ce que vous réagissez quand vous
apprenez que le père du tueur donc cet
algérien qui vit dans son pays envisage
de porter plainte contre la france pour
la mort de son fils bien j'ai honte
voilà je suis outré comme tous les
français
voilà que dire de plus vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure des prêches enflammés
dans certaines mosquées françaises
il ya un instant mais vous jugé odieux
en même temps le rapprochement qui a été
fait par marine le pen entre les mêmes
de l'immigration et du terrorisme
néanmoins vous estimez j'ai trouvé
absolument odieux qu'elle puisse dire
les mohamed et c'est qu'ils arrivent à
ce moment sont de futurs tueur j'ai
trouvé ça ça m'a coupé le souffle et je
me suis dit qu'en fait elle était comme
son père j'ai trouvé ça au dieu parce
que ne confondons pas vraiment ne jetons
pas l'anathème sur une population et je
voudrais dire à marine le pen qu'il ya
des français des jeunes français qui
sont de confession musulmane qui sont
arrivés sur eux sans doute les bateaux
dont elle faisait état et qui sont morts
en afghanistan sont le drapeau français
il y a des français des jeunes français
de confession musulmane qui se sont
engagés dans l'armée française il ya
beaucoup dans notre armée est donc on
n'a pas le droit
quand on est un responsable politique de
souffler sur les braises comme ça ça
nous choque je suis un républicain
gaulliste je n'accepte pas ça néanmoins
ce qui n'interdit pas en revanche et de
vouloir rétablir un état de vouloir
établir des frontières de vouloir
contrôler l'immigration
mais de grâce qu'on ne mélange pas tout
contrôler l'immigration parce que vous
estimez qu'il ya trop d'étrangers en
france
j'estime
kylie a un devoir d'intégration
important que dans une société qui a
perdu un million d'emplois en dix ans il
est totalement irresponsable de faire
entrer deux cent mille étrangers parents
légaux et je ne parle pas des illégaux
que les entreprises françaises
certaines entreprises font venir alors
même offert une bière se chiffre à 100
millions
comme nicolas sarkozy l'a reconnu je
leur en suis heureux en tout cas c'est
le bon sens c'est de dire quoi sous
lionel jospin
il va y avoir à peu près 100 milles ça
fonctionnait je pense qu'on est passé
d'ailleurs sous nicolas sarkozy à 200
milles c'est assez stupéfiant
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
lois ne sont pas appliquées
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas traité le
problème de fond du problème de fond qui
est l'attrait par des chefs d'entreprise
ce que j'appellerais pas malhonnête mais
malsain qui font venir des main d'oeuvre
bon marché
et puis il ya un problème qui aura la
solution mais qui fondamentale et dont
on ne parle pas dans cette campagne
c'est le développement de l'afrique
c'est la stabilisation du maghreb et
quand je propose un euro protectionnisme
euroméditerranée j'ai une vraie vision
de ce qu'il faut faire pour l'afrique et
le maghreb
et si on ne traite pas ce dossier
africain on aura des problèmes
migratoires considérable vous êtes dans
la campagne vous avez beaucoup de choses
à dire je viens pour vous êtes aussi
contester on va le voir dans un instant
notamment sur vos propositions
économiques
le retour de la démence on va en parler
avec un rire dans un instant assis mais
la notion de frontière est revenu dans
la campagne à travers également nicolas
sarkozy ou henri guaino qui en parlent
sont simples humains
est ce que vous estimez comme henri
guaino qu'il ya un problème avec les
immigrés ou certains américains on
n'arrive pas à assimiler tous ceux qui
sont là y'a pas de problème avec les
immigrés il ya un problème avec la
société française qui ne crée plus
d'emplois qui a une école qui est devenu
laxiste et qu'un état faible et donc la
question c'est pas de jeter de l'huile
sur le feu à l'égard des immigrés parce
que leurs enfants sont français et pour
la plupart sont des bons patriotes
remettre le prônent la haine étape
économique et social
et moi j'en ai assez de voir monsieur
guaino écrire des choses très justes
mais servir un président de la
république pas du tout servir un
président de la république qui fait l
inverse
c'est ça le problème de fond parce que
sinon ce serait merveilleux
je prends un exemple le président a pu y
parle de l'europe passoire mais c'est
lui nicolas sarkozy qu'à signer le
traité de lisbonne qui a abandonné le
droit de veto de la france dans les
négociations commerciales
donc moi je suis candidat pas pour
commenter les autres on les a assez vu
je suis candidat pardonnez moi pour dire
aux français qu'on peut agir
différemment et pour proposer un projet
qui tient la route
alors je vais pas commenter
éternellement les actions des autres
puisque de toute façon les français ont
jugé
ils savent que ça tient pas la route
simplement ils sont perdus parce qu'il
voit bien que hollande ça serait pas
mieux
ça pourrait même être pire ils voient
bien que le front national c'est l'excès
est justement moi je suis candidat parce
que je veux proposer un patriotisme
républicain avec des mesures économiques
radicalement différente pour relancer la
machine
on y arrive on y arrive la longeur
encore une question nicolas dupont
aignan vous rejeter le parti socialiste
vous rejetez l'ump vous employez
d'ailleurs la même expression que marine
le pen le système ump est utilisé ça
fait 30 ans a tourné au bras c'est le
même langage
mais cbs que j'ai on a le droit de
parler librement dans notre pays c'est
tout de suite qu'on nous parle de marine
le pen bail
ça c'est la vieille lune pour toute
personne qui pense différemment que
l'ump est ce qui nous gouvernent depuis
trente ans je vous ferai remarquer 15
ans socialistes 15 ans trois
législatures socialiste 3,3 ump je
voudrais vous fais remarquer qu'ils ont
laissé la france dans un état
catastrophique les deux la
catastrophique et ces deux partis qui
ont échoué en tout qui ont un bilan
accablant veulent monopoliser la vie
politique et se servent du front
national comme repoussoir
et bien justement ça va gêner que moi
j'arrive et que je vais dire aux
français vous pouvez vous passer d'eux
sans tomber dans le piège du front
national alors vous acceptez quand même
que je dis
ce qu'il y a des similitudes pour le
moins entre votre projet est celui de
marie pourquoi vous ne dites pas que des
similitudes entre mon projet est celui
de monsieur montebourg
pourquoi vous ne dites pas que les
similitudes entre mon projet est celui
de monsieur nikonoff d'attac qui a qui
vous propose la sortie de laurent
jeanpierre la gauche
néanmoins quand j'en amis non mais c'est
très intéressant je vous réponds parce
que c'est jour le jour je vais bien
madame le pen jamais visé parce que je
vais vous répondre
j propose parmi les candidats les dix
candidats à la présidentielle de sortie
de l'euro sinon vous et marine le pen
alors on voit ça et on en parle et on en
parle plus alors il attend le paysage
politique et communique certes mais dans
la présidentielle si nicolas dupont
aignan on voit ça avec marie brémaud
avant d'accueillir hervé hasquin des
gens bien que vous avez réseau argumente
et si nicolas dupont aignan était légale
masculin de marine le pen
à y regarder d'un peu plus près les
similitudes sont nombreuses les 2
propose l'abandon de l'euro le
rétablissement des frontières
ils veulent tous les deux revenir à ce
qu'ils appellent l'europe des nations et
les deux veulent un certain
protectionnisme économique deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
pour un seul et même programme
abandon de l'euro retour au franc
instauration de droits de douane pour
relocaliser l'activité en france stricte
séparation des banques de dépôt et des
banques de crédit priorité absolue aux
pme mais les analogies vont bien au delà
des mesures économiques le pen dupont
aignan même combat pour l'abrogation de
la loi hadopi le rétablissement des
frontières la création massive de places
de prison
la réduction drastique du nombre
d'immigrants sur l'immigration les deux
vont dans la même direction
mais marine le pen va tout de même plus
loin que nicolas dupont-aignan sur le
regroupement familial
marine le pen veut la suppression du
regroupement familial monsieur du
poignant de sa suspension pendant cinq
ans marine le pen est la seule a prôné
la suppression du droit du sol est
également la suppression de la
binationalité donc avoir un petit peu
plus loin tout serait une question
d'histoire de passer d'héritage celui de
nicolas dupont aignan souverainiste dans
la lignée des pasqua et ce gain est plus
facile à porter que celui de la
candidate frontiste
elle doit composer dans son parti
avec une frange véritablement radical
extrémistes anti système anti
républicaine ce n'est pas le cas mais
nicolas dupont-aignan sont là dessus
mais quand même un peu plus à l'aise à
l'aise le président de debout la
république les suffisamment pour
envisager marine le pen à matignon si
lui accéder à l'elysée
voilà je veux répondre parce que ça ça
fait partie de la ritournelle pour faire
peur aux français
et pour leur faire croire qu'on peut pas
être patriote et républicains donc c'est
facile mais j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit le
jour où marine le pen abandonnera cette
idéologie xénophobe extrémistes et
qu'elle reviendra dans une républicaine
je pourrais comme montebourg ou
mélenchon la m comme premier mini c'est
pas du tout la même chose est sûre et
j'insiste là dessus parce que justement
ça fait 20 ans qu'on nous a mis dans le
piège du front national
et moi je dis qu'on peut être patriote
mais qu'on peut rassembler tous les
français je n'ai jamais fait la moindre
différence entre un français de quelque
origine quelle soirée
d'où qu'ils viennent et je n'accepte pas
je n'accepte pas cette volonté toujours
d'extraits mise et les gens qui sont
patriotes
ça a été fait à une époque elle
chevènement qui était ridiculisé par
canal+ dans les guignols on se faisait
passer pour un fasciste alors
chevènement est éteinte républicain je
suis à gaulliste républicain je n'ai
rien à voir avec le modèle de société
marine le pen
je ne veux pas déremboursés les vg je ne
veux pas rétablir la peine de mort j'ai
un autre modèle de société et j'aimerais
que ce soit dit hervé hasquin avant soir
donc sur le projet économique ne nicolas
dupont aignan résumé d'ailleurs dans ce
livre le printemps français à programme
très détaillée mois après mois montre
bien qu'il est beaucoup plus sérieux que
celui du front national
bonsoir nico nicolas dupont aignan alors
j'ai une question à vous poser devrait
se situer dans un exercice on a fait un
exercice de politique fiction et
peut-être même des coloris fiction la
nana pour moi en tout cas nous allons
nous projeter dans l'avenir
imaginez que vous déconnez dans les
sondages nous quitter la zone de
relégation pour être qualifié vert
ce consentement sakineh ce sont des
français qui disent et de vos personnels
patients d'âge les ménages non plus
l'idée journalistes mais vous êtes au
second tour et vous êtes élu bon dans
ces circonstances élu quelle est votre
première décision économique sortir de
l'euro oui bien sûr enfin il y en a
peut-être une autre avant la première
décision économique
c'est de mettre en place un
protectionnisme minimum lorsque les pays
émergents triche avec toutes les règles
du jeu ce qui est le cas aujourd hui les
problèmes des pays émergents non mais
c'est un vrai problème mais c'est un
vrai problème celui l'économie française
n'est pas tournée vers les pays
émergents mais p le nombre de chômeurs
j'ai rencontré d'entreprise délocalisé
parce que la décision était prise
d'aller produire en chine à 50 euros par
mois avec des esclaves nouveaux esclaves
pour accumuler les profits ça c'était
très concret et je vous renvoie sur le
million d'emplois industriels perdus
tout n'est pas lié c'est évident tout
n'est pas lié vous avez raison aux pays
émergents mais si on ne met 10 passes
stop à l' échange déloyal d'ailleurs je
me réjouis puisque aujourd'hui même à
gauche au parti socialiste
même l'ump commencent à réaliser que
j'avais raison on parle c'est juste
échange mais oui bah c'est une façon
élégante
sauf qu'il faut passer à l'acte je vais
vous donner un exemple tant rire à
l'euro un exemple très concret
la chine vient d'interdire l'importation
de bouteilles d'evian et de volvic sous
prétexte que c'est dangereux pour la
santé
l'union européenne vient de signer un
accord avec la corée du sud
c'est même le responsable de peugeot qui
sonne nouvelle qui autorise
l'importation de voitures de corée du
sud en europe mais qui interdit en corée
du sud
je veux dire que c'est le le
démantèlement total et inégale des
barrières douanières
il faut mettre fin à cela si on veut
éviter qu'on perde encore cinq cent
mille emplois industriels dans le
prochain quinquennat mais poussé en ce
jour 160 % du commerce extérieur
français
c'est vers l'union vous avez raison et
c'est pourquoi et c'est pourquoi il faut
agir aussi sur l'euro d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire sur l'euro il n'y a pas que
l'euro et le protectionnisme
il faut baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés
qui réinvestissent en france il faut
remettre les banques françaises au
service de l'économie réelle
il n'y a pas du tout que des affaires
extérieures nous avons aussi nos propres
défauts soyons clairs églises ou go est
un point clé fondamentale j'étais hier
dans charente chef d'entreprise vient me
voir et me dit monsieur vous avez raison
dans mes exportations j'ai créé une
entreprise aux états unis
j'en ai une autre en france je
délocalise aux états unis parce que je
suis en zone dollar l'euro c'est 20 30 %
de ceux révolution monétaire
tous les gains de productivité que je
fais ils sont bouffés par la monnaie je
n'arrive plus à produire en zone euro
offrir leurs autorités nous mais une
décision question suivante et un homme
sur la situation de relative de la
france et de l'allemagne les deux pays
appartiennent à la même zone agissent
dans des conditions économiques
politiques similaires appartiennent à la
même union européenne sont les deux
moteurs de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui
et pourtant il y en a un qui fait 150
millions 1 150 milliards dont d'excédent
et commerciaux et un autre france
malheureusement soit 170 médard y allait
à déficit commercial
eh bien vous avez les barrières et des
pourris mais des barrières les barrières
douanières elles servent à quoi
eh bien je vais vous dire une chose très
claire pas de barrières douanières à
l'intérieur de la zone euro je veux pas
mettre des barrières douanières
je vous ai parlé d'un protectionnisme
quand il y avait des concurrences
déloyales comme la référence quand on
est en concurrence loyale je n'ai pas de
protectionnisme et il n'est pas question
je pas une france fermée
en revanche avec l'allemagne c'est
évident 150 milliards d'excédents d'un
côté 70 milliards de découvert de
déficit de l'autre
ça veut bien dire que la situation
mérite une action très rapide à cette
fabrique à armes égales on aura les
bourgeoises et là ça veut dire que les
français ne sont pas comme les allemands
oui ça c'est fait ça veut dire aussi
qu'il ya un pays on suscite
démographique en suicide démographique
qui va avoir dans 20 ans un problème
majeur est un pays en france qui a 40 %
taux de chômage dans les quartiers qui a
une croissance démographique
donc c'est déjà pas le même pays
deuxièmement c'est un pays qui a pas là
la structure industrielle
troisièmement c'est un pays qui n'a pas
le même effort de défense et les mêmes
dépenses publiques
quatrièmement c'est un pays qui ne veut
pas agir pareil cas par la même
tradition économique alors il ya deux
solutions
soit on dit comme le fait la classe
politique depuis dix ans il faut qu'on
soit comme les allemands en paroles
c'est très bien sauf que ça aboutit à la
ruine de la france soit on comprend que
la monnaie et vous êtes suffisamment
érudit dans ce domaine que la monnaie
c'est un élément qui doit être adaptée à
la compétitivité
dans la vie il faut pas une monnaie trop
cher il faut pas une monnaie trop faible
la france est morte dans les années 30
est de laval qui a fait une politique du
franc fort qui arrivait exemple en 36
alors que l'angleterre avait compris
qu'une monnaie c'est un moyen en sorte
de l'euro alors d'abord leur revient
hall d'évaluer combien arrêtent alors on
prend l'hypothèse où vous avez je vais
vous répondre en sort de laurent blanc
ont dévalué de mon bien si je peux vous
répondre
d'abord je suis au regret de vous
annoncer que même si je ne suis pas élu
l'euro sera probable probablement fini
avant la fin du prochain quinquennat y
lire une raison très simple
certains disent aujourd'hui qu'on est
sorti de la crise bien sûr mais bien sûr
j'en prends le pari ici mais revenons en
donc attendez là mais j'aurais quand
même répondre parce qu'il ya la
situation de l'espagne qui est en train
d'arriver là grand v dans quelques jours
que personne ne voit et l'espagne est
dans une situation en impression vous
frotter les mains
je me frotte pas les matches je vois la
réalité que la petite place parisienne
ni parce qu'elle veut pas voir né dans
le dogme en allemagne j'ai des amis
allemands
professeur d'économie un vrai débat sur
l'europe est d'accord on écoute
est-ce qu'on peut regarder votre jeu
vous devez lui convient et je ne dévalue
pas je transforme un euro en un euro
franc d'accord ensuite les lois du
marché fonctionne plusieurs banques ont
étudié ont modélisé nos murs à une autre
qu'est-ce qui se passe l'euro marque ce
réévaluera de 20 à 30 % conformément à
la compétitivité allemand ce qui évitera
les excédents excessifs de l'allemagne
deuxièmement le relire et l'euro dragons
se dévalue rond fortement l'europe et
êtes au regard de leur compétitivité et
il est estimé que leur offrant des
allures a déjà mans entre 10 et 15 %
légèrement
oui et c'est que je chance c'est une
chance ça peut arriver mais ça veut dire
une explosion aussi l'upa ou du pétrole
mais bien sûr mais je vous réponds alors
attendre encore et les beats 700 euros
près d'un milliard d'euros de dette de
la france qu'il faudra rembourser en
euros deutsche mark comme vous l'avez
dit alors ça c'est la fable je vais vous
dire pourquoi
ainsi pour deux raisons d'abord je veux
vous de répondre sur la valeur de la
monnaie
pourquoi tous les pays du monde sauf la
zone euro aligné sur l'allemagne font
une politique de mots n'est pas trop
cher pourquoi le sont ils si c'est si
dramatique que ça pourquoi la chine sous
évaluer sa monnaie de 50%
pourquoi monsieur cameron qui tient tant
à l'euro pour nous lui a laissé filer
cela livre de 20%
pourquoi la suède s'en sort les 4% de
croissance cette année
pourquoi le zloty polonais a été lissée
le 20 % pourquoi les états unis monsieur
obama tiennent à ne pas avoir à dollar
trop élevé il faudrait vous m'expliquer
ça c'est la première chose curieuse il y
a que vous qui savez et tous les autres
sont des âmes non mais peut-être que le
croire que l'europe pourrait réviser le
malheur de famine mais hélas dans une
position commune ça l'allemagne ne veut
pas donc il ya bien un moment à en tirer
les conséquences si l'europe voulait
changer l'euro ça serait ça fait dix ans
qu'on le demande
les socialistes l'ump ils échouent ils
sont à genoux et ils perdent les emplois
donc moi je veux qu'on agisse et vous
devez parler avec nos voisins européens
mais bien sûr projet suit sont d'accord
bien sûr j'ai été en grèce en espagne en
irlande il ya beaucoup de pop qui ont
compris que l'euro allait fanny louis
enfin peut-être et hypothèquent dont les
vous savez on est notre assise l'époque
compte plus que ces rixes les dirigeants
certes les gouvernements les
gouvernements d'aujourd'hui sont
temporaires parce que quand vous
condamner un pays comme l'espagne à 50 %
taux de chômage pour sa jeunesse quand
dans nos quartiers en france et 40 % de
chômage quand en grèce c'est le chaos
est ce qu'on a le droit de traiter
l'europe comme ça donc moi je ne propose
pas de tout casser
je propose une monnaie commune beaucoup
d'économistes ont proposé leur au franc
l'euro marque avec une monnaie de
réserve
et je propose cher monsieur que cette
monnaie permettre enfin de produits sur
le continent européen et en france je
propose ensuite pour la dette je vais
vous répondre sur la dette parce que
c'est un point très important je propose
enfin qu'on rétablisse la capacité de la
banque centrale a financé à 0%
les grands investissements publics et je
propose la monétisation qui est chiffré
dans mon programme sur mon site internet
il a été modélisé chiffré nba 2012 vous
verrez nous proposons de monétiser 100
milliards d'euros par an à 0% comme
l'angleterre le fait en ce moment et
comme saul williams tout cela est d'être
bien voyez vous pourrez dire que je ne
suis pas la seule chose mélangeant parce
que cette petite classe politique à
mener la france à la ruine estime qu'il
faut continuer bon elle serait très bien
pour résumer ce que vous voulez
renationaliser la france non non parce
qu'il faut l'initiative privée et je
finis ma phrase l'a tous eu d'accord en
monétisant 100 milliards par an à 0% et
réduit la charge de la dette l'intérêt
de la dette qu'on paye chaque année en
2017 nous paierons plus que 30 milliards
au lieu de 50
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
20 milliards d'économies sur les
intérêts d'emprunt parce que je pense
qu'il est préférable de moins payer sur
les marchés financiers et avec cet
argent de financer mes mesures pour
l'économie productive baisse de moitié
de l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
bénéfices réinvestis en france ça veut
dire rupture des accords européens
c'est ce qui se fait aux états unis je
veux dire sortie d'union rappeler leur
renégociation aux états unis monsieur
cantat chef d'entreprise investis il un
impôt qui diminue quand il investit sur
le sol américain
pourquoi on peut pas le faire en france
deuxième mesure recrutement pour les tpe
exonération de toutes charges sociales
pour un chômeur de longue durée car il
vaut mieux payer le manque de charges
sociales que payer des allocations
chômage de longue durée cinq milliards
d'euros pour un emploi par tpe pendant
cinq ans cinq milliards d'euros de nom
recettes pour la baisse de liesse 5
milliards pour l'aide pour les chômeurs
de longue durée
10 milliards d'euros au lieu des pays
aux banques jund sus de la création de
richesse dans notre pays
c'est ça l'enjeu ce que vous ne
comprenez pas c'est qu'on peut pas
continuer dans un pays où celui qui
produit en france et défavorisés par
rapport à celui qui délocalisent mai
mais cette france repliée sur elle même
et par plier si on cède 0,6 à l'endroit
des droits au feu des droits de douane
aux frontières est sûre avec son ex
amène avec les autres elle est replié
pardonnez moi le cinéma français est ce
qu'elle est replié je pense qu'il est
très ouvert sur le monde et la
concurrence et l'expérience vous
présentez quota de quotas de
consommation est présent sur scène oui
france est bien le cinéma français en
france marche bien donc vous acceptez
pour les acteurs de cinéma et les
metteurs en scène ce que vous refusez
pour les ouvriers eux l'analyse in c'est
parce que je me sens à l'aise entre les
oeuvres de l'esprit et puis la fermeture
c'est vrai que la douleur est normale
non c'est beaucoup moins important que
de savoir si le petit milieu de paris va
pouvoir me rend si neymar ce que je suis
pas sûr que je n'ai pas lu moi je vous
le dit pourquoi la malaisie pourquoi
l'argentine pourquoi le brésil pourquoi
le japon
pourquoi l'allemagne par l'oedt en
allemagne volkswagen je me suis
renseigné j'ai vérifié quelque chose
volkswagen le land de basse saxe est
actionnaire à 20% il ya une loi
particulière qui interdit aux
actionnaires privés sur le marché
d'avoir plus de 20% du droit de vote
c'est à dire que les 75% d'actionnaires
privés ne peuvent pas décider pour
volkswagen
donc il faut arrêter avec cette fausse
idée du repli la mondialisation c'est un
combat et dans le combat on a le droit
de se protéger mais cette france revient
à dire que l epa repliées davantage
alors cette france qui est passé la nuit
oui enfin dans un univers moins
concurrentiel avec une économie comme
les autres comme la chine ou alors elle
sera plus compétitive mais est-ce
qu'elle sera plus compliqué a bien sûr
parce que quand vous n'êtes pas en
concurrence avec une monnaie de 20% trop
cher 20% trop cher quand vous faites pas
face au dumping
quand vous avez des banques qui aide à
la création de richesses et quand les
charges baissent sur les pme au lieu de
payer des intérêts d'emprunt pour une
oligarchie financière qui s'en met plein
les poches et qui a échoué
c'est quand même pas la même chose pour
les entrepreneurs alors je ne sais pas
la même politique ce qui s'en excuser ma
les poches
pouvoir oui les évoquer dans un instant
avec perrine tarneaud qui va nous
rejoindre merci merci hervé perrine
arrive donc juste après cette enquête
deux tomes traduits sur vous elle est
beaucoup de peines à celle à faire
parler d'autres souverainistes même si
vous n'aimez pas le mot pour but vous
même la coopérative my love c'est un
bourbon oui dang tran huy charles pasqua
philippe de villiers jean pierre
chevènement
lionnel luca ou encore jacques myard la
galaxie souverainiste englobe des
personnalités politiques de tous bords
et elles ont toutes un point commun
aucune ne veut ou ne peut parler de
nicolas dupont aignan une histoire de
rancoeur ou encore de mépris à l'égard
du petit candidat qui a créé son propre
parti à debout la république
on préfère prudemment par les deux
routes qui se sont séparés aujourd'hui
l'ump a trahi un certain nombre d'idéaux
gaulliste qui était résiduelles suite à
la fusion du rpr avec démocratie
libérale aujourd'hui ces idéaux sont
défendus par debout la république et
quand deux chemins politique se sépare
forcément une forme de concurrence des
divergences de points de vue il y en a
eu dans le parcours de nicolas
dupont-aignan le président de debout la
république a côtoyé à peu près toute la
planète politique de droite
à ses débuts il rejoint le rpr et sera
proche de philippe séguin
avant de s'inscrire au rpf de charles
pasqua et de philippe de villiers en
2002 malgré son soutien à jean pierre
chevènement
il rejoint l'ump et forme le club
gaulliste debout la république
un mouvement qui devient finalement un
parti en opposition à la décision de
nicolas sarkozy de contourner le non au
référendum de 2005 sur le traité
constitutionnel européen
cette déception fondatrice c'est
vraiment fait le viol du vote de 2005 et
le choix de passer par le congrès et non
par un référendum pour valider le traité
de lisbonne
c'est à partir de ce moment là en fait
que la déception est devenue définitive
et que nicolas dupont aignan a décidé de
partir dans un parcours totalement
indépendant des grands partis alors un
fidèle nicolas dupont aignan un brin
versatile peut-être ou déçu devant
l'éternel par la machine des grands
partis lui qui se dit ni de gauche ni de
droite se retrouve aujourd'hui isolées
sur l'échiquier politique est seul face
aux français sous l'ombre tutélaire du
général de gaulle dont il revendique
l'héritage
même s'il ne l'a pas beaucoup connu
qu'on puisse dire bonsoir c'est très
cohérent
moi j'ai essayé je viens de la droite du
rpr je suis gaulliste j'ai adoré
philippe séguin j'ai combattu maastricht
avec lui j'ai jamais changé d'opinion
j'ai combattu amsterdam j'ai même
démissionné de mes fonctions rpr j'ai
rejoint philippe de villiers ils sont
après arrêté je continue c'est très
cohérent
c'est très cohérent indépendante mais
seuls mais sol mais je suis pas seul
j'ai la chance d'avoir un parti
politique qui a de plus en plus de monde
mais en ile de france on n'ait plus de
onze mille adhérents en ile de france on
me disait 0% dernières régionales
on est quand même passé devant le modem
les besancenot keitel et coqueluche des
médias sol ça veut dire quoi vous
regardez les chiffres des sondages mais
ça me fait hurler de rire moi je vais
vous dire je suis quand même élu maire
dans ma ville depuis 1er enfin mieux élu
de france en mieux tout premier tour 80%
mieux élu de france
je me souviens quand je me suis présenté
les sondages me disait trois jours
claude ménard et un désagréable si trois
jours avant l'élection les sondages
disaient il sera jamais élu est le
premier tour législatives je suis le
seul à avoir gagné dans la dissolution
une circonscription de gauche à droite
on me disait jamais aux régionales 0%
on a dépassé le modem vous savez les
sondages sont faits pour enfermer les
français qu'est ce que vous espérez leur
piège mais j'espère convaincre les
français qu'on peut bâtir une autre
politique est dépassé au moins un match
mais vous pouvez être méprisant bien
nous dire quand on parle des mecs mépris
de certains scores 2% des voix c'est un
million de français moi je crache pas
sur un million de français quand la vie
politique regarder les écologistes ils
ont eu des hauts et des bas ils ont
quand même influencé beaucoup le parti
socialiste moi je crois que la france
parce que c'est ça la vraie question
je crois que la classe politique
française est au bout du rouleau
je pense que très vite la situation va
s'aggraver et que la vraie question pour
les français c'est de savoir s'ils
veulent continuer avec cela ou s'il vole
trop
v la solution qui va permettre avec des
efforts ça ne viendra pas du tout
tombera pas du ciel
sortir de la crise et c'est ce que je
vais proposer à la france
voilà et puis on verra ce que diront les
français c'est un long combat qui
commence mais aucun mépris de notre
jugement
mais que les fans de chez vous mais
parfois on jours est il que c'est
certainement un des deux grands partis
français qui va remporter cette élection
présidentielle soit le parti socialiste
soit l'ump en tout cas c'est ce que
semble indiquer pour l'instant galets
sont ajournés à peine on en profite aux
français la question quant à laisser les
français jugent sur la droite
nicolas sarkozy a réuni toute la famille
toute la droite autour de lui du centre
enfin la fatigue de la france du oui la
france du non vous vous faites plus tous
partie de cette famille là bas est
aujourd'hui non puisque cette famille a
trahi la france mais je le pense
donc j'ai pas vous dire le contraire du
coup il mène une politique
une folie il mène une politique qui est
en train de précipiter notre pays dans
un chaos économique et social
j'en pèse mes mots et je sais la gravité
de ce que je dis donc ps ump dans le
même sac et je finis ma phrase la
gravité de ce que je dis parce que moi
je vous dis une chose madame si on
continue cette politique de l'euro cher
du libre échange déloyal
on a déjà perdu un million d'emplois
industriels en disant il suffit qu'on en
perde deux à trois cents mille encore et
des partis pour ça veut dire non je
finis ma phrase ça veut dire que la
sécurité sociale et les retraites ne
sont plus financés à partir de fin 2012
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
prochain président de la république
oui madame qu'ils soient de gauche du ps
du ps totalement in est sans aucun
programme où monsieur sarkozy seront
face à une colère sociale et un chaos
politique sans précédent et il est de
mon devoir d'homme politique depuis 15
ans député je les ai vus vivre je les ai
vus voter n'importe quoi sans prendre en
compte l'urgence de la situation
eh bien il lui montre mon devoir d'homme
politique de dire aux français il faut
changer rapidement de cap si on veut pas
aller sur le récif
alors voilà on l'a dit vous l'avez vous
l'avez
ça veut dire que pour le deuxième tour
vous n'appelez à votre jour c'est ça qui
n'en tirez pas des conséquences il est
quand même rare sinon parce qu'il ya un
premier tour est-ce que vous excluez de
voter n'est que l'avis un cosy oui je ne
vous répondrai pas il ya un premier tour
non parce qu'il ya un premier tour
d'accord bien sûr on le sait mais anna
holcim et on veut le véhicule faisait
aujourd'hui qu'il veut zapper le premier
tour je n'ai pas d'opposition
personnelle aux sommes d'accord que ce
soit nicolas sarkozy ou françois
hollande
soyons clairs à nicolas sarkozy -
françois hollande qui dirait demain
matin on sort de l'euro on se protège
on mène une autre politique ont dénoncé
traité de bruxelles je suis capable de
tracter d'abord il se produira pas et
vous n'en savez rien bon petit questions
d'actualité maurice lévy à la tête de
publicis va toucher un bonus de 16
millions d'euros
c'est un montant qui vous choque honte à
lui honte à lui l'a pas mérité
non non je vais vous dire sur les
résultats dans la ville
honte à lui ont différé et je vais vous
dire il devrait avoir honte
ce monsieur ne sait pas dans quel pays
vit j'ai dis honte
il a signé récemment une pétition pour
dire que les riches devaient payer plus
d'un plat sans doute
eh bien écoutez moi je dis que quelqu'un
qui vit en france d'aujourd'hui où deux
millions d'enfants deux millions
d'enfants sont élevés dans notre pays
sous le seuil de pauvreté un pays qui
jette ses ouvriers ces agriculteurs un
agriculteur par jour se suicide dans
notre pays et est ce que ce monsieur que
je ne connais pas je n'en veux pas
personnellement se rend compte de ce
qu'il est en train de faire au détriment
de la libre entreprise
parce que moi je crois que l'avenir du
pays viendra de la libre entreprise de
la création de richesse est ce qu il se
rend compte un instant de ce qu'il est
en train de faire autre je crois pas
notre question dans la semaine ne le
ferai pas si c'est un homme sensé
je crois que c'est un homme intelligent
donc il devrait y renoncer et le
partager entre tous les employés de sa
société
on verra s'il entend le message de la
classe politique aujourd'hui dans l'
affaire bettencourt l'ancien
gestionnaire de fortune de la famille
patrice de maistre est en prison il y
reste
est-ce que vous pensez que derrière
hermès d'ailleurs eric woerth il y a le
financement occulte de la campagne de
sarkozy en 2007
moi je ne suis pas un justicier je suis
pas juge
en revanche je demande que la justice
passe et que le président de la
république éventuellement s'explique
voilà il a le droit de s'expliquer voilà
en tout cas je demande que d'un côté et
pas de justicier moi je suis pas père la
morale mais en revanche il faut pas
qu'ils aient l'omerta et le fait que
monsieur l'est sont en prison je ne sais
pas si c'est justifié ou pas il n'est
pas condamné
il est mis en examen d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est simplement que justice
passe et il est clair qu'il faudra un
jour que le président de la république
s'exprime quand même avant la fin de la
campagne
on est rentré dans la campagne
officielle de cette élection
présidentielle ce qui vous permet
normalement de vous exprimer à égalité
avec les autres candidats dans les
médias les médias se donne du mal en
principe en principe est ce que vous
êtes satisfait participation 5 6 1
contre 2 pour les élections irie de
choses je suis satisfait qu'en
république pendant cinq semaines sur 260
semaine d'un quinquennat y ait une
égalité de traitement
c'est normal quand on envoie la
profession de foi vous ça vous allez
recevoir votre domicile le papier il n'y
a pas un timbre poste pour les dix
petits candidats et et 10 pages pour
ceux qui sont favorisés par les sondages
depuis la fondation de la république
la profession de foi à la même taille ce
que je regrette un peu parce que c'est
un peu mesquin c'est que tout le monde
n'est pas comme vous c'est qu'il ya
certaines chaînes qui supprime les
émissions politiques
peut-être parce que les règles du jeu
sinon les règles du jeu sont très simple
vous les faites la plupart le font ces
dix émissions où beaucoup de chaînes
supprimés émission politique c'est
scandaleux et c'est mauvais pour la
démocratie c'est mauvais pour la
légitimité du futur président deuxième
point je regrette une chose c'est qu'ils
aient pas de débat et que messieurs
sarkozy et hollande
pareil vous allez dire que je leur en
veut à tous les deux ne veulent surtout
pas des pâtes avec monsieur mélenchon
avec madame le pen avec monsieur bayrou
avec monsieur dupont-aignan
parce qu'en fait comme il raconte
n'importe quoi aux français et qu'ils
savent très bien qu'ils ne mèneront pas
après 2012 la même politique que des
annonces ne veulent pas qu'on leur pose
des questions et je trouve ça quand même
très frustrant pour l'opinion que il est
pas des débats
comme lui pour la primaire socialiste
finalement pour une élection privé il ya
eu plus de débat et pour une
présidentielle c'est quand même dommage
les toits concernant votre en tout cas
merci à vous parce que vous c'est la
seule émission longue qu'on a et on le
fait avec beaucoup d'entrain de jos et
vos arguments
là c'est moi aussi méritent d'être
entendus à propos de votre futur
élections légistatives éventuelle si
vous n'êtes pas élu ce avant l'arrivée
des cahiers et reconnaît bien vous êtes
brillamment réélu non seulement à la
mairie mais comme député vous aurez un
adversaire de l'ump en face de gros je
le pense ah oui je l'espère mais ne se
serait que j'espérais un mot pour
conclure sur la guerre en examen pour
proxénétisme aggravé de dominique
strauss kahn ça vous inspire une
réflexion grandeur et misère du pouvoir
j'en sais rien il n'est pas condamné
encore une fois j'ai revoir des
justiciers en politique très bien très
bien ce sera le mot de la fin
voilà même si vous voulez régler son
compte à la monnaie commune
on peut avoir est bien exposé j'essaye
d'expliquer à mes convictions je suis
sincère on peut au moins de reconnaître
sa merci à vous et perrine merci merci à
nicolas dupont-aignan ont été heureux de
vous recevoir aujourd'hui ni l'odeur une
autre édition de preuves par 3 tout à
l'heure et notre invité sera jérôme
cahuzac qui chargeaient du 22h30 chargé
du budget la fiscalité auprès de
françois hollande
merci et la semaine prochaine nathalie
arthaud de lutte ouvrière lo recevoir
leurs propres moyens qu'on priorise
sommes rien
jean pierre raffarin également pas dans
la même émission je vous le rappelle
voyez qu'on peut y arriver
on y arrive on y arrive bonsoir et c'est
vrai que les auditeurs sont ravis des
téléspectateurs d'entendre toutes les
voies de la campagne bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être notre compagnie
ce soir les trois thèmes de cette
campagne 2011 seront la crise la crise
et enfin la crise que la politique ce
n'est pas la guerre civile a donc dit
xavier bertrand
parler de ce printemps du jasmin
sa victoire si elle est vérifiée demain
parce qu'elle surprenante
comment vous jugez son action dans cette
tempête
quelle époque on avait tous ri
aujourd'hui on rémois votre rendez vous
quotidien avec la formation c'est du
lundi au jeudi à 22h sur public sénat
les agriculteurs ont toujours voté à
droite d'une campagne à l'autre vous
emmène dans le morbihan chiffres et
derrick et jean-michel des éleveurs qui
n'ont pas encore choisi leur candidat
notre expert des sondages ne niera
ensuite vers qui les agriculteurs se
tourneront en 2012 enfin suis venu dans
les cortèges d'europe écologie les verts
avec christian militant alvan il se
démène pour que la question du nucléaire
ne passe par le second plan la bretagne
première région agricole française en
2007 nicolas sarkozy et les autres
candidats par le peu d'agriculture
pourtant dès le premier tour plus d'un
agriculteur sur deux choisit le candidat
ump
depuis les difficultés se sont
accumulées concurrence internationale
volatilité des prix et autres sécheresse
une période de crise inédite fait douter
un monde agricole en pleine mutation
d'une campagne à l'autre direction
l'exploitation de saint loup est en
plein coeur du morbihan c'est parti
chaque matin chaque soir pour frédéric
c'est le même rituel
et ça dure depuis cinq générations
aujourd'hui la traite de ses 145 vache
va rapporter trois mille quatre cents
litre de lait vendu à la coopérative
voisine oui mais voilà depuis 2007 les
prix font du yoyo et rendre le quotidien
parfois insupportable on n'avait pas le
choix de continuer mais pour dire quand
le matin et où savait que c'était
quasiment rien gagné
ces problèmes à t aujourd'hui et les
prix du lait ont retrouvé des couleurs
et frédéric un peu de sérénité
ce soir là jean michel son associé est
venu lui prêter main forte
sa production à lui c'est la dinde la
grande spécialité du morbihan pour les
entend chanter comme ça pour nous c'est
un critère important c'est ça sera juste
à chacun sa spécialité et ses problèmes
pour élever ses 1300 d'inde
jean-michel chauve son hangar à près de
25 degrés et sur le gaz
difficile d'économiser c'est un coût est
important de l'élevage en trois semaines
on a des actionnaires lotole singles
garges ça correspond à peu près à donner
aux 30000 euros cette année et une
facture en augmentation de 20% depuis
deux ans aux décharges baisse des prix
de vente des produits pour lisser leurs
revenus les associés séduit par le
grenelle de l'environnement se lance il
y a trois ans dans l'énergie solaire 760
1000 euros investis 1200 panneaux
installés et la promesse de revenus
durables confrérie qui avait lancé cette
idée là c'était 2
de fait d'amener un autre nouvelle venue
sans savoir trop de travail aujourd'hui
nous avons atteint
en dix mois l'objectif de production
annuelle une production delà de leurs
espérances mais toujours pas le moindre
centime de retoucher edf tarde à signer
les contrats et la baisse de 20% du prix
d'achat de l'électricité verte décidées
par le gouvernement a douché leurs
espoirs
on était on n'est qu'à la santé quelque
part c'est vrai que ont ce qui de notre
histoire
non on ne peut pas dire l'état vraiment
rempli son rôle
on ne l'avait promis au départ chez les
paysans bretons la révolution verte est
en marche quinquas en attendant il se
verse 1500 euros net par mois pour 70
heures de travail hebdomadaires le prix
d'une dure vie de labeur parfois
récompensés lorsque frédéric et
jean-michel la traite est terminée ça va
maintenant être l'heure de parler
politique
messieurs alors en 2007 une grande
partie des agriculteurs avaient choisi
de soutenir nicolas sarkozy est ce que
vous aviez voté tous les deux assez
présidentiel c'est à dire que on a voté
pour mais c'est sarkozy à l'époque il y
avait un certain dynamisme de fichiers
donc on pensait tous que l'avenir à led
plus beau que le passé puis avec la
campagne ils ont été très dynamiques
quel regard aujourd'hui vous portez sur
les cinq années passées au pouvoir par
nicolas sarkozy mais beaucoup d'effets
d'annoncé et souvent après peu d'actes
et ça dans le monde agricole on n'aime
pas beaucoup
dans le monde à une épaule bien on a une
caractéristique 'cela va leur donner la
parole
la façon dont s'est passée les cinq ans
on se pose vraiment la question si on
sera encore à l'art tellement tellement
c'est compliqué qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
demain que l'état prenne comme décision
pour que votre agriculture reste
compétitive et que vous ayez des revenus
honnête en allemagne des énergies
renouvelables se sont développés mais de
manière très très importantes alors chez
nous on a dit qu'on allait le faire on
l'a fait et après on a fait un moratoire
donc on fait toujours les choses à
moitié voire au carré aujourd'hui on se
trompe de route
la campagne présidentielle débute à
peine le premier tour ce sera le 22
avril prochain
2012 est ce que vous savez déjà pour qui
vous allez voter
j'ai pas envie de voter pour la même
chose en tout cas jusqu'ici je la trouve
pas très intéressante
je trouve qu'on ne prend pas assez
d'exemples qui fonctionne on dit voilà
c'est le marché mondial c'est la crise
la bourse et mais de là à nous sortir
une vision des choses
c'est pour ça pour le moment j'attends
on à vis d'un reportage que vous êtes de
plus en plus sensibilisés à
l'environnement au développement durable
est ce que ça voudrait dire que demain
vous pourriez voter écolo pas si on nous
propose de d'arrêter de produire je
pense que c'est sûr que ce sera pas
possible de voter écolo et des façons la
décroissance a ses limites parce qu'on
va pas non plus mais tout le monde au
chômage et je pense que on peut
travailler ensemble à condition que pas
qu'on nous écoute aussi et conviennent
pas avec une solution toute faite qui
nous dit de nous agriculteurs soit
disant classe et productiviste bas
débarrasser le plancher bois
jean-michel frédéric merci et puis bonne
continuation à vous en 2007 plus de la
moitié des agriculteurs français avait
choisi nicolas sarkozy